negli episodi precedenti ma andando
verso il caesars palace vorrei in
sostanza è un c è un centro commerciale
con l'acqua
questo è il punto più vicino dove puoi
arrivare alla scritta sta andando come
vi avevo già detto alle hawaii se questo
nell'aeroporto dell'aula gli stellini
che volano dentro l'urne o vabbè sento
parlare di questa terra da sempre
dentro la rivolta ci sono gli uccelli
dentro c'è tutto cio l'uccello stavo
dicendo che i ragazzi ho chiamato nube
eccolo qua il mio huber perfetto
arrivato
a non è lui e poi vj
ragazzi ho conosciuto
si vede che la gente mi sta sui [ __ ]
no perché oggi non giornata nuvolosa ho
parlato col driver e mi ha detto che
oggi è così ma domani per fini giorni
non sarà perché sono arrivato al mio
albergo ashton waikiki proprio di fronte
alla spiaggia siamo al diciottesimo
piano perché la mia stanza e al
diciottesimo piano e sono andato un po
sull'economico errata non ho speso
tantissimo per l'albergo perché tanto ho
detto adesso da solo
mi dici pure che perde ma anche
niente
eccolo eccolo
bad ragaz ci sta
ci sta a veder levi e con le views on
dit angola le visualizzazioni ma la
vista
acqua jazz luca
mi sa che ma sentita tutta waikiki mamma
scuola la pasta ai una volta la uai che
fai vantati fronte oceano ed ai e su
pensavo molto peggio perché non l'ho
pagata troppissimo in realtà cioè
spendevano più i miei ad andare sempre
capelli spendevano più i miei ad andare
a riccione in realtà trova addirittura
mi ha messo pure due bottiglie di acqua
guai anche c'è scritto che si possono
riempire una volta che l'hai finite
totalmente gratis cioè ma ragazze l'ha
firmata anche jason momoa minchia
firmate da acqua man e subisce
probabilmente vi fa scassare che quando
arrivò negli alberghi c'è la centrale
nucleare attaccata per ricaricare tutto
sembra una minchia di spia della delle
pr all nite life delle hawaii è molto
più tamarra
di quella che ci si possa aspettare è
come rimini il sabato sera lo state
leggendo anche voi ragazzi il nome del
locale vero cioè non sono pazzo io qua
kiki crisma store pensa che business ora
che ad aprile
ma 21 il tatuaggio dettagli dettagli
quando sei un vecchio alle hawaii
ed è sulle rive dell'oceano
il primo giorno di hawaii che mi accorgo
che le palme
la cia non sono nel truman show solo che
non lo sapevo un giorno mi sono
svegliato da
40 secondi più o meno
e merita tale signora ed accordi che
d'accordo scusi mi caga scendiamo
vediamo che succede
ragazzo non giappone non lo sapevo e
siamo arrivati al gran momento in cui si
pesta richiesta con piede la spiaggia
hawaiana questa è una delle principali è
una delle più turisti che in realtà
quindi non è isolata sostanzialmente ma
fa niente
nei prossimi giorni proveremo anche le
altre per adesso vediamo sono più che
altro curiosi di sapere se l'acqua è
fredda come in titanic oppure se si può
vivere può decidere se guardare la città
con le palme di sfondo tutto fighissimo
o se guardare
l'oceano specifico c'è un bel panorami
know
tutto piego l'acqua bastard il pd
pensano tagliato la mano tanto qua ci
sono gli squali sono nella merda sapete
che non ho la minima idea se sta roba
può meno andare sott'acqua
la vista ne sa
io ne so un po meno piccola parentesi
ragazzi per adesso state vedendo
honolulu che è la parte più turistica
delle hawaii nel prossimo video sempre
sulle hawaii vedrete anche la parte un
pochettino più isolata dove c'è molta
meno gente le spiagge sono ancora più
belle però per adesso concentriamoci
sono l'uno e sto cercando un posto dove
pranzare e vorrei provare in qualche
ristorante hawaiano ma alla tempera
vaturi joe sua brutta quando avevo
parlato con il driver che mi ha portato
all'hotel mi aveva detto che oggi ci
sarebbe stata una fiera qualcosa di
strano tuttavia qua
adesso andiamo a vedere cosa c'è
san lorenzo in bikini ma se in italia
mangiamo il poche hawaiano alle hawaii
mangiano italiano la risposta è sì a
quanto pare acquisto della fiera e nel
proprio comodo come l'estate però c'è
raga mentre camminavo a caso qualcuno ha
ficcato la scritta free in questro mezza
l'asma perché
dell'ingenio chi l'ha fatto un genio
allora l'isola e questa è l'obiettivo
andare dall'altra parte quindi per
arrivarci vedete che c'è tutta la strada
sono due ore e mezza devo prendere il
trasporto pubblico ho preso il mio
pranzo a sacco e adesso adesso si va ora
vi faccio ridere
154 fermata
154 la destinazione tra l'altro si
chiama la mia amica
va bene
siamo a while mea valley ci sono un
sacco di tavolini in uplink ci sono un
sacco di tavolini da picnic niente male
perché dire no a questo punto andava a
rimini c'è questo scoglio ragazzi da
dove la gente si tuffa direttamente
molto figo se vi aspettate che io faccio
una cosa del genere non lo farò per la
vostra sicurezza
non sarete sulle rocce
c'è una cascata tipo la zona sottolinea
ballo grazie presentimento proprio la
scritta con riprendere la valle dei
preti no raga sto male va beh hanno
fatto un sacco di film qua dentro cioè
vicino a questa cascata addirittura
hunger games tarzan ma che ha figli lost
ma dove ma chi ma dove ma cosa
bellissimo non mi chiamo io da loro
posto incredibile costa fare sta roba
costa soldi
mai io che cazzo all'entrata raga king
camera mea primo king cameraman a
lillo tra la tua
luca lani
ragazzi è un paradiso terrestre
c'è anche l'aster culliamo non sperma
io
sono a casa o magari perché si può
notare qua dentro ma siete pazzi non so
se la penso che faccia un freddo boia
che figura e la cascata è bellissima
adesso effettivamente capito dove hanno
girato hunger games c'è anche il muro
dove finisce la rena di hunger games
avevo visto questo posto prima da
lontano ragazzi siamo un po il cammino
che hanno fatto nel signore degli anelli
pratica la mordor ce l'hanno
attaccato
è decisamente un posto paradisiaco c'è
scritto ragazzi che vietato nuotare se
avete dei dubbi
in che senso cioè il dubbio se c'ho
voglia mi tuffo anche se c'è uno tsunami
praticamente costa
quanto costa sta a casa tranquilli
fatevela pure la casa tranquilli
tranquilli gli indici mi sono vista
questa
dai cazzo una volta che riprendo
[Musica]
io e la mia vita
stavolta ce l'ha
ok raga allora c'è un punto molto carino
che però per arrivarci un po tortuoso il
passaggio nemici di prendere sa però non
mi sembra st strada proprio adatta a 1
che camminano nel dubbio mi sono proprio
messo dall'altra parte del guard rail
tutto cacato è la cosa più tenera che
abbia mai se un po di vento che strano
la madonna è una sorta di ieri ser
ma che figata sembra l'effetto che
faccio io alle ragazze ma incredibile
attenzione non andare dietro questo
punto tutto imbrattato la gente perché
non essere da meno raga sto male sto
male ma che figo non mai visto un posto
leggerezza che poi dalla camera su come
non rende mi hanno detto tra l'altro che
questo esatto punto qui è dove hanno
registrato la scena di pirati dei
caraibi quella con la sirena attenzione
attenzione
ma cosa vedo lì se i videogiochi mi
insegnano giusto la c'è una questa
secondaria e ci andiamo subito musica di
zelda quale ma così
ma attivo la luce non marca c'è una luce
in fondo la videogioco ora quel punto
qualcuno sto male ma che cazzo nero
ragazzi per cui
mi chiamo rispunta goal un mio testo è
stato tale comparto ma non lo faccio
bene mi sembra la caverna di the forest
ci manca sto male sorride flores che
ricevono sto malissimo ma cos'è and
turkey terribile non si vede niente
a sto mano che posto che minchia voce
qualcuno milan c'è un'uscita
non mi chiedevo arrivare all'uscita se
mi crolla tutto in testa sono morto però
nel senso avete visto il film quello
delle catacombe di parigi era roba lì
terribile o esso e catacombe già delle
hawaii no vabbè ma con lui ci passa
neanche un topo croce uscita lì mi in
chiara che come faccio io devo troppo
arrivarci
ecco che cazzo faccio una ragazza è
troppo basso non posso passare qua mi
crolla tutto in faccia
no terribile striscia devo strisciare
c'è per uscire di la devo strisciare
quindi non lo posso fare o lo faccio
perché sono un pazzo
va beh devo essere impazzito guida
lingerie la mannaia chi tempo ma che
cazzo me l'ha fatto fare
ho visto qualcosa che si muove
io vado via
vado via si
pianta